so that was a lot to absorb you got the
15 minute primer on what's going on on
campus you'll be hearing much more about
the details of the kinds of things that
president Bollinger was talking about
how we're involved internationally
what's going on with manhattanville the
exciting intellectual things that are
going on on campus the amazing
architecture that's there and just you
know it reminds me just what an
incredible opportunity we have as
students at Columbia and how the
university is really growing and going
forward I before I go any further I just
want to thank the columbia alumni
association Donna McPhee and the
wonderful staff they have been working
twenty-four/seven to make sure that
everything runs smoothly for us today so
can we just thank
as president Bollinger was saying we are
leaders Columbia is a leader in the
world global leadership and as alumni
you are leaders in your own fields
benefiting from the wonderful Columbia
education and we want today to be able
to bring those links together to link
you into the world of Columbia to use
you to take Columbia farther into the
world beyond the campus and just to
solidify those relationships you know I
feel very privileged to be a part of
this wonderful alumni body at Columbia I
went to the journalism school I began to
get involved in volunteer ways and
working with the Alumni Association and
Irina Stern is here Irina where you
stand up Irina is our wonderful staff
person there and Irina and neck and some
of the development office people sort of
roped me in slowly but surely and you
know and I just have to say I loved
every minute of what I'm doing there
with the CAA as a trustee really getting
a chance to have an insider's view of
what's going on and this first panel is
going to give you a deeper understanding
of what it means to be a leader within
the university within the administration
as well as what alumni are doing and to
really look at their perspective what
the challenges are what role of alumni
play so let me just introduce our
panelists you Claude Steele is the 21st
Provost of Columbia University as well
as a professor of psychology and a
leader in the field of social psychology
his most recent book whistling Vivaldi
and other clues to how stereotypes
affect us and what we can do was
published in 2010 I recommend it to all
of you there's some really great stories
he makes all of these issues of race and
ethnicity really interesting and really
compelling the story of whistling
Vivaldi you'll have you can see him on
c-span you just type his name and go to
c-span books and you can see his speech
Michelle moody Adams is an ethicist
known for work on moral relativism and
moral objectivity Dean of Columbia
College and vice president for
undergraduate education and you know I
I'm from Indiana you don't know that but
anyway when I first met Michelle I'd
learned that she had lived in
Bloomington so I felt an immediate
connection and Fred Van Sickle is our
new executive vice president for the
university development of alumni
relations he came to Columbia in 2002 to
help lead our efforts in reaching out to
alumni worldwide and he is leading that
incredible 5 billion dollar Columbia
campaign effort so I'm going to take my
seat with them but I just like to get
started and let Claude I tell us from
your point of view as a university's
chief academic officer what are the
biggest leadership areas and challenges
for columbia today thank you one thing I
just begin by saying it's I'm relatively
new to Columbia this is the middle of my
second year but I feel like I've come in
a particularly fortunate and exciting
time it's like getting on a train that's
really going in very interesting journey
yet so it's an exciting day by day
experience and I will wind up to sort of
amplifying many of the things that
president Bollinger just told you about
but I tell you down on the ground it is
really an exciting I feel privileged
position to be in to help this train
move along I like to just touch on a
number of themes our expansion what's
going on in our sciences which do tend
that set of issues has tended to
dominate my work and thinking and a few
words about globalization and diversity
if I can get to those all those issues
in five minutes or seven minute the
challenge with the sciences you can't
you have to begin with the with the
the great opportunity of the expansion
of Columbia University there's the issue
of the the great achievement of our
acquiring manhattanville the
manhattanville space and beginning to
build buildings on manhattanville this
as Lee just mentioned is 18 acres of
land it's as big a plot as the
Morningside campus itself is and a
hundreds of thousands millions of square
feet new square feet will be added to
our University and the new space of
course opens up the opportunity to reuse
and reconfigure the existing space and
so that you can just begin to see that
we're really this expansion really
reconfigures Columbia gives us an
opportunity to really reconfigure
Columbia and take on some really
exciting opportunities and chances in
the area of science science is perhaps
among the the various fields if you
think of humanities and Social Sciences
and the natural sciences science and
engineering are perhaps the most space
dependent academic endeavors and so they
are really at the center of the first
wave of development in this expansion as
academic expansion it's that's taking
place at Columbia as Lee mentioned in
the way I think of it is there are two
buildings we have that really open up
new space and as I also mentioned the
opening up of that new space and the
moving of some faculty into that new
space opens up old space for rethinking
but the two buildings one is is already
up to great distinction and great
acclaim the northwest corner building
rafael moneo building that lead just
described it's a 13-story science
building with labs and on the top I
think 11th floor is the first two floors
have classrooms of library and a
magnificent cafe if you're ever in the
area it's a great place to to visit this
gives us a chance to I think revive and
rejuvenate our sciences traditionally
Columbia has been a great
University we have as many Nobel Prize
winners in the sciences physics
chemistry biology as any University
throughout the 20th century but in the
past decades it's been those areas that
have been more restricted by by lack of
space and so these buildings give us a
chance to rejuvenate that tradition and
we're all very excited about it and i
think one concrete way to think about it
is it gives us a chance to improve the
rankings of our of our science
departments they're very distinguished
departments and they're very well ranked
but we would like to bring them all into
the top five if we possibly can that is
a real institutional goal with regard to
the space and the future of the sciences
at columbia in in that respect i think
there are two ways of thinking about
this the northwest corner building opera
offers us an opportunity to simply
expand the science departments and give
them some of the space that they haven't
haven't had and to a higher new
scientist and to develop real foci of
interest there that that strengthen the
department's but it also gives us a
chance to explore the experience the
possibilities of interdisciplinary
science many of the cutting-edge issues
in science are now addressed by teams of
scientists who come from different ones
chemist chemists physicists engineers
biologists all working on the same
problem with labs next door to each
other postdocs of of different trainings
in within within labs and so on so we're
trying to in the northwest corner
building give that kind of science of an
opportunity to develop and take root in
the institution then as we move into
manhattanville the first building that
will open and that this is a
particularly exciting focus war for
columbia because we're so strong in
neuroscience may the mind brain and
behavior building will be probably the
biggest neuroscience research building
in the in the nation or in the world
there are room for 70 scientists there
they
we'll cover the range of neuro
scientists from those who look at at
neuroscience phenomenon at the cell
level all the way to the behavioral
level so on one end you'll have cell
biologists on the other Angela have
psychologists economists political
scientists all who are beginning to
explore the relationship between in
particular the brain and mental activity
of all sorts we now have this capacity
to image and observe a brain activity as
it corresponds to mental activity and
bringing that range of scientists
together in a single building we're
excited to imagine this very yeasty kind
of scientific environment so it's with
that building that we will open
Manhattan villain and have the highest
hopes for it again racing to my five
nights right I can begin to feel you
here mobilization lately did a great job
of describing the the approach we're
taking to globalization of the
University it's important to say not
every university in the country
especially our publics that they really
don't have the opportunity to pursue
this in quite the same way that our
private institutions do we're all
looking for the right way to configure
this effort do you build a whole campus
aboard abroad do you put an executive
training program abroad I'm particularly
proud of the idea that we have developed
here of putting a network of global
centers around the world because I think
it gives us a special capacity to work
with with those regions in developing
the issues and the content that those
that those centers were will focus on it
really in the in the era as this as this
effort begins it really sets up a great
dialogue between Columbia University in
the regions of the world where the
centers are and so I hope this will give
our centers especially good rooting in
those areas and then as time goes on and
we hope faster rather than slower it
will begin to offer offer a lot of
opportunities
too certainly for faculty scholarship
and research but also for our students
to to be in a region of the world as
they study the material that's relevant
to that region of the world as everyone
knows that can be a life-changing kind
of an experience so we're especially
proud of this idea and and working in a
long as best we we can at this point
well I'd better stop thank you well
thank you for you know I i hate to sort
of keep saying the same word over and
over again but excited is the way that I
feel when I hear about all these things
I hope you share that word Lee mentioned
it as well but I just think that that's
really what you're going to feel by the
end of the day I hope that these
comments make you really want to visit
campus you have to see that new building
at the northwest corner and take a visit
up to manhattanville and get a sense of
what's going on so Michelle as dean of
the college you are Dean of a school
where that is one of the most
sought-after places i think i was
reading yesterday only seven percent of
the six point six points okay nine over
all right percent so this is a place
people want to go all the things that
Claude is talking about tell us where
we're going to be leaders how are you
developing leaders within the college
what are some of the challenges what are
some of the initiatives well the college
has long been known for its academic
leadership in ways that we're all very
proud of particularly the storied core
curriculum which preserves the best of
the Western tradition and now invites
students to engage also with the world
around them in the global dimension but
we are also now becoming particularly
strong at blending the best of academic
traditions with the most promising
intellectual innovations and in fact we
really are extraordinary leaders in this
area and I'm focused my comments on
three specific kinds of innovations that
I think we are doing best dad the first
will I hope come up note as no surprise
to all of you in this room that as the
world gets more complicated
some of the boundaries between
disciplines need to be broken down more
often than we might expect disciplines
are wonderful but some things that
happen in the areas between the
disciplines are important too and at the
college we're developing a number of
interdisciplinary academic programs that
really allow our students to study at
the forefront of change in me in the
Academy one example is a new major in
sustainable development it's really
quite extraordinary I think we were the
first of all the top research
institutions to develop such a major
that brings together student assoc ology
economics engineering as well as biology
chemistry physics to prepare students
who want to go out into the world and
encourage change in several areas that
will also bring about change without
doing harm to the world that's really
the kind of mission of the sustainable
development program and it really is
quite an extraordinary offering another
area in which we've been encouraging
that interdisciplinary work is in work
we allow undergraduates to do now with
some of our professional schools on
campus these are extraordinary important
resources for our students I think one
of the reasons we're so popular with so
many students is that we can offer these
kinds of opportunities for instance we
now allow majors in the college in any
subject to supplement the major with
what we call a special concentration the
equivalent elsewhere of a minor in
business management and this is not an
excessive or extraordinary departure
from the value of the liberal arts
education that we continue to celebrate
because we still require the core
curriculum we require all the
conventional visions of a major but we
say to students if you think you want to
go out into the world of business we can
give you the opportunity for a little
preparation in advance of that it's a
really a wonderful minor and it actually
incorporates courses from economics
along with courses in the business
school several other programs are
planned with Public Health and what the
loss
cool but they're still in progress I
don't have all the details there
secondly we've got some wonderful new
initiatives in science and I am perhaps
myself especially proud of where we're
going with this the college has long
been known rightly so for its strength
in the humanities and the social
sciences and as in humanists I continue
to celebrate the importance of those
areas but we know that in the 21st
century a student can't be a person
can't be a responsible citizen unless he
or she has some appreciation for methods
of argument and ideas in the sciences
obviously some students will come
wanting to major in the sciences and so
we're doing a lot more to attract and
retain strong science interested
students with new research opportunities
in the sciences some of them year-long
academic year long opportunities some in
the summer we have designed curricular
changes to accompany these research
opportunities so we give students
seminars that prepare them for the
research and or even rethinking some of
our introductory large science courses
to make sure that everybody who comes in
interested in science if they wish to
continue can in fact find their place in
the discipline even in the core
curriculum I think this is especially
exciting we continue to develop a pilot
course that was developed six years ago
now called frontiers of science that
gives every incoming student in the
college the opportunity to study methods
of argument ways of reasoning even
notions of scientific risk and evidence
to understand when they leave Colombia
how important it is to be to have some
scientific literacy and we're really
quite proud of that and then the third
area links up with many things you've
heard this morning from president
Bollinger and also from provo steel in
the area of global initiatives not
everybody appreciates that even with a
core curriculum with a very demanding
set of requirements twenty-five percent
of our undergraduates go to study abroad
number might be getting larger but for
us that's extraordinary and so it's
important to keep our science our study
broad program strong one of the things
we're doing is encouraging faculty to
consider both new kinds of study abroad
models so some models of study abroad
our year-long semester long program but
perhaps students can profit from two
weeks or four weeks or six weeks abroad
taking part in some kind of academic
Enterprise along the way we're also
encouraging faculty to develop programs
that work with the global centers that
sustainable development major I
mentioned professor kevin griffin is
developing a course that will take
students a way to the sump to the
program in amman tickets for about six
weeks to do some work in forests and
farmland there on sustainable
development questions so we're really
quite quite proud of that and then one
final fact about the poor in addition to
a new way of thinking about science in
the core there is now a global core
requirement a two course requirement
students have to study some dimension of
thought or action or practice or
political life in a non-western context
whether its comparative or in an
individual culture and with the help of
some of our most generous alums we've
been able to offer faculty some course
development opportunities to for summer
workshops to refine or rethink courses
they're teaching or introduce new global
dimensions and what they do and so
there's a lot going on in all the areas
that we've heard are important in a
campus-wide way the college is really
participating as a leader and we should
all be very proud
thank you very much Dean moody Adams and
we will hear more from her later she'll
be moderating a panel with students so
we're going to drill down even more
deeply so thank you very much so Fred
you spend a lot of your time building
relationships your I would say your
whole life almost is talking with alumni
and of course the money that is being
raised helps us become a leader helps us
develop initiatives talk to talk to us a
little bit about how leadership how
alumni can can be leaders and
participate with you well we think that
alumni engagement really is an essential
ingredient of the momentum at the
University and it this really begins
when when Lee actually did his inaugural
address he talked about the need for
Columbia to be much more accessible to
its alumni and have more meaningful and
important connections so we work very
very hard at that and see you all as
being an essential part of all that we
do in a whole range of ways actually I
want to mention I was with Lee and
others here in Istanbul just a couple
weeks ago which is a perfect example of
the impact of alumni in so many ways one
of the main reasons why we're going to
have a center in Istanbul is that a
group of alumni decided that we want to
have a global center here and so through
their energy and their time and their
money that's going to happen that's just
at one tangible example of that I think
they're a number of ways one is that
alumni leadership is so key to the
University and we actually see examples
of that here today Lee is an alumnus we
have 24 trustees ilili is one of them
they're all alumni and their passion and
their commitment is essential also to
driving the university's agenda and then
of course we have two hundred and
seventy thousand alumni that we can keep
track of around the world and thousands
of them are alumni and give to the
University and that's just a huge thing
for us I do want to mention in the
campaign where we've had a lot of
success so far over that time period a
third of all of our alumni have given to
Columbia in that time and that's a huge
thing for us and something we're
continuing to work on and those gifts
that folks give fuel all the projects
that you talk about here at
manhattanville the curriculum financial
aid science and on
on and Columbia really is committed to
this kind of engagement and there are
lots of tangible examples the creation
of the columbia alumni association about
six years ago the creation of our first
alumni center on campus on 113 street i
help when you're in new york you'll come
visit us we have an alumni Welcome
Center we're very proud of that and also
we work really hard around the world
with our alumni we have 80 alumni groups
around the world twenty of those have
been created in the last five to six
years and interestingly 15 of those
twenty new ones are in the international
locations so again the engagement in a
new way really spans the globe we also
work hard on programming and social
networks and work hard to do what we can
to highlight our faculty and our alumni
and their accomplishments and connect
those with alumni we have so many people
we're proud of I mean being in
Washington DC with President Obama and
Attorney General Holder and then
examples like today where we have
distinguished alumni on our program or
whether we're in Sundance and and
highlighting filmmakers we take great
pride in the accomplishments of the
members of the community so we actively
seek to build this network and there are
lots of ways that people can be involved
I think probably all of you are in one
way or another whether it's helping us
build career services around the campus
law alumni offering summer jobs to
lawyers studt law students for instance
interviewing prospective students
helping us even today with the Columbia
community outreach there I guess 19
cities around around the country the
world where alumni are doing sort of
service projects on the guise of the
columbia alumni association so we really
welcome your involvement and we see this
really as a work in progress we think
we've made great progress over this last
decade but we know there's a lot more
that we can do and should do and that we
can be more effective we can certainly
be more effective with your help and
your involvement and your advice and we
encourage that and we're very glad
you're here today
thank you very much for it you know
because I know everyone can't absorb
everything that's being said today I
just want to remind you that we have
fantastic websites and I think Stella
was going to put that up so columbia.edu
I hope all of you will visit and David
Stone who's our vice president for
communications is here David where are
you can you David in the room David's
probably doing some work he's probably
responding to rotc questions but the you
just just so you know our website has
just really has just been redesigned
it's really fantastic easy to navigate
there was just a webcast on the japanese
earthquake and tsunami which claude
moderate right a thousand people 2011 i
tuned in so don't you know go to the
website often and you can see what's
going on and then I think we also may
have a slide with one another one of the
Columbia publications Columbia magazine
so I just wanted to make sure that you
know about that right put it in your
haha take out your iphones and right in
the the website would turn off your
phones i mean don't have them ring I'm
not the ring but you can make a note or
write it down on a piece of paper the
old-fashioned way but I just want to
make sure that you're aware that now we
have time for a couple of questions and
I think we have microphones on either
end so if you don't mind going to the
microphone since it's being taped would
you indulge us please and if anyone else
has a question maybe go to the line up
at the microphone we appreciate that
yeah Andy bi Columbia College 54 54 54
okay yet known on an age I was in ROTC a
common not that not to beat a dead horse
here but I would like to know and I was
also played basketball baseball so I was
little discouraged Albert's about some
of our athletic ability over the years
but I'm real proud of without our new
athletic director I really am she's
doing a great job getting back to NROTC
I heard about the president talking
about debate now I seem to remember that
President Obama and mr. McCain Senator
McCain at Columbia debated services to
the country all right and both agreed
that honor nrotc should be back on
campus both agreed remember McCain
brought it up said and president before
President Obama cause he was not
president then he was campaigning agreed
with senator mccain so i'd like to see
the debate end okay well i thank you we
should who should do this well I think
it has ended I think vote yesterday
maybe Lee Lee actually from all I hear I
couldn't be there myself but Lee
actually did a great job I think of
managing that debate and you may have
something to add to it but but my
impression is that that that now we have
we have had a good process about that I
did moderate an earlier debate of
faculty and graduate students and that
was the third of three so I think all
sectors of the community
a chance to think about this expel upon
it I I'm I sort of proud of it again as
a relative newcomer I I like this
tradition of debate I think people learn
a lot from each other by hearing each
other talk about things that they really
care about so i don't i don't think it's
it's really something you can think of
as it's just window dressing i think its
intrinsic to to what a university does
is to be a place forum for that kind of
exploration of issues and i think we we
gave it about the right amount of time
and and yesterday's vote in the in the
senate i think for the community brings
this to a handsome end i think that this
this is an environment really where you
can't do things by Fiat and I just think
it would have been uncomfortable for
everybody but now the voices have all
been heard and the atmosphere on campus
has changed a lot there are some
incredible veterans who are students
there who are you know interacting every
day and we've had a chance to hear from
some of them I think they you know the
mood on campus among students is
welcoming for the most part and it's
it's really different from 1968 so but
it did have to go through a process i
think i think if Lee had just said this
is this way or this is that way it
really wouldn't have been very you know
it just wouldn't have worked i mean the
you know as lee says the president can't
just tell people what to do you have to
let people sort of talk about it and
figure it out and i think that it did
happen in a very positive way other
questions yes hi I'm Natalie Blackburn
I'm a prospective student for mailman
school of public health and there there
are a number of prospective students and
recently admitted so I'm really welcome
to all of you
I just had a question you talked a lot
about the international effort global
efforts the different campuses can you
talk a little bit more about the
relationship with New Yorkers and sort
of efforts being made to interact with
the community I know you said there's a
community day volunteer day maybe touch
on efforts made recently to sort of
expand on that and work in the city well
I'm yes Michelle I'm sure that others
will add to what I say but there is a
very active engagement on the part of
students faculty and staff at Columbia
with the surrounding community just to
give you one example is a program called
community impact which gives hundreds
almost a thousand I think students the
opportunity over a given year to
volunteer in the community to do work
that also has a connection to the
academic program as well in a way that I
think we're all very proud of and there
are many other initiatives some of them
coming from the professional schools as
well that connect our cambia community
members with the larger community I
think we can all be proud so this one
day that's going on now is only an
instance of something that happens all
year round right Claude or any other
nation I would just mention I know that
there are that the dentistry school has
clinics where they provide services in
the community the law school has clinics
where they provide service in the
manhattanville project we have a
connection to a city school that focuses
on science and our and our it's not our
school but the science faculty i think
is very involved in the curricular
development of making that a unique
educational experience and I think the
list could go on and on yeah i would add
one more specifically college program
called double discovery which connects
columbia college undergrads with high
school students well actually middle and
high school students in the city in
programs they come every week for
tutoring for mentoring and then we see
them through to the application process
for college so there's a lot going on
it's great question and you'll so you
can see more on the website as well
don't forget that website and with
manhattanville there's a very formalized
community
benefits agreement where Columbia has
committed millions of dollars to
community initiatives that will be
rolled out as manhattanville is
continued is continuing to be developed
there are also programs where people in
the community are employed through
during the construction phase of
Manhattan deals there are lots and lots
of things going on we can do one more
question I think that's me okay great
I'm Deborah standards class of 91 the
business school you may have just
answered my question because it's
related to the previous question I live
in Harlem and I know that there has been
the development of the expansion some
tension between the school and the
community over the years and so I was
going to ask how did you make peace with
community board nine I think I'm hearing
some of the answers but it would be
interesting to know some of the details
behind the funding that you just
mentioned fork programs in the community
what are some of the things that are
going to be rolling out over the next
couple years well it's and the others
can say something too but there's a West
Harlem Development Corporation like a
Harlem development corporation that is
working very closely with our other
office of government affairs so there's
a we have a wonderful vice president of
government affairs Maxine Griffith who's
from Harlem originally who you know
they're all the other people in the
administration who were working but
Maxine has a personal connection and the
Uhler process which leave which makes
Lisa nerves it's a very complicated very
political process we were able to
negotiate our way through that in a very
wonderful way and everybody held their
breath but it it worked and I think it's
because people understand that Columbia
is one of the largest employers of
people in that part of Manhattan and
really dedicated to being a good partner
you set it on okay all right so um bread
Michelle Claude closing closing thoughts
well this may sound self-serving and I
don't I don't also explain why it isn't
in a minute but but I do i do think as
you're thinking about your alma mater
that it's it's it's you're allowed to
think now that we're in an especially
good period of leadership I think
Columbia is has been the reason it's not
so self-serving because I'm new to this
administration I can't take the kind of
credit for it I'd like to but but i do
think over this last decade especially
columbia has moved into an era where its
leadership has been innovative
insightful courageous it's taken on some
of the real major challenges that higher
education in general faces I think it's
come up with some of the more innovative
and substantive solutions to problems
that that higher education faces and
that Columbia itself faces as at the
University so I think it is an era where
Columbia is repositioned itself as a
major leader in higher education doing
some of the more adventuresome things
that I think of any of our peers the
expansion itself and the academic
expansion it goes with that I think it's
a good example but but we're in a period
of good leadership and it's a time for
the whole community to rally to that
fact I'd want to say that the framework
for all the things I talked about
earlier other curricular innovations is
our leadership in the area of access and
this lets us do two things it lets us
bring what is the most diverse class of
undergraduates to a great institution
called Columbia College and as we bring
the most diverse they are also some of
the strongest I heard just on the way
here for this event that the average s80
score of the most diverse class in
Columbia history has just gone up six
points it's the highest ever in our
history so diversity quality right it's
already tuned access and I'm very proud
of us for that and I just reiterate we
just welcome your participation and
invites your feedback and coming to
events and sharing your resources and
your time with the University you're
really important to us and we hope that
you share our pride in all that's
happening at Columbia so as they would
say and there's more we are going to
hear from some of the leading experts on
health care and public health after the
break I would like to see everybody back
here at ten fifty eight nine eleven but
1058 so we can get started promptly at
eleven thank you so much